[Musique]
toute l'industrie de la restauration
étaient réunis à montréal à la gare
windsor hier soir pour la quatrième
édition des prix des lauriers de la
gastronomie québécoise et parmi les
seize lauréats et à l'entreprise
économie sociale montréalaise les filles
fattouche qui a remporté le prix
entreprise de l'année un plaisir ce soir
de recevoir à adele tarzi bachique et co
fondatrice de l'entreprise associée
geneviève comeau qui est associé
également directrice générale bonsoir à
vous deux bravo et félicitations
je présume que c'est un prix important
ça représente quoi pour vous que de
remporter ce prix là c'est vraiment une
pierre fierté jusque le nom des filles
fattouche il est là parmi toutes les
noms des dans la domaine de landes
l'industriel gastronomique du québec ça
nous donne comme une vraie fierté d'être
là et de participer à cet événement là
c'était très touchant oui je présume que
c'était très touchant les filles
fattouche c'est quoi les faits pas
touche est né de l'idée de participer à
l'intégration des réfugiés seriez en
2007 donc l'idée était d'intégrer
particulièrement les femmes pour qui
c'est plus difficile parce qu'on cesari
quand ils arrivent en famille les femmes
vont être en charge la maisonnée des
enfants et elles sont plus souvent isolé
donc en leur offrant de l'emploi on les
sort de l' isolement on leur
créer un cirque social et elle gagne
aussi en autonomie et puis c'était
facile parce que là que la culture
culinaire et les millénaires et je
transmet de mère en fille les familles
syriennes donc chauffer cuisiner mais
c'est ça c'est de la cuisine et de la
cuisine avec des femmes syriennes
réfugiés l'intégration la mission
sociale c'est ça il vous fait de la
cuisine oui on fait de la cuisine et on
a toute une gamme complète des épices on
voulait aller au delà on voulait donner
plus d heures de travail on apporte
toutes nos épis sont les en ballon les
étiquettes avec notre équipe dans notre
cuisine on voulait réunionnais la
cuisine la richesse de notre pays
histoire de réfugiés c'est une strophe
triste mais on voulait vraiment montré
d'autres face d'eux des réfugiés syriens
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont emmené avec eux
toute une fierté toute une richesse
parce que là on a accueilli au canada 25
mille réfugiés syriens du début 2015 à
mi 2016 bien sûr avec ce qui s'est passé
avec la guerre en syrie vous avez
embauché plusieurs signes chez vous ici
rien les cv c'était vraiment simple et
faut juste qu'elle soit une femme
chilienne qui est là statut de réfugié
et c'est parti au nom de la molécule
curieux non non c'est le pont entre les
deux cultures
si rien ne filtre canadien québécoise
donc on a deux missions c'est d'intégrer
les femmes et aussi de créer des ponts
entre la culture syrienne la culture
québécoise et canadienne et ce lien là
ils viennent la nourriture parce qu'on
pense que c'est en découvrant la
richesse culinaire d'une culture qu'on
découvre toute la richesse de son peuple
et pourquoi les filles touchent ses
coiffures fattouche la salade ça tousse
et une salade très colorée elle présente
vraiment elle est toujours au milieu de
notre repas quel que soit un repas
quotidiens ou un repas festive donc on
voulait mettre un nom qui est pas triste
un nom qui présente notre culture est un
os qui présente les syriens qui sont
nous nous sommes un peuple vivant on
aime la vie on aime les couleurs
on voulait présenter cette culture là et
cette mission là on a choisi un nom qui
attire l'oeil et le ventre oui oui et ça
donne faim même quand on en parle ne
serait ce que quelques instants comme ça
comment vous êtes sortis de la pandémie
parce que hier il y avait ce grand gala
avec les gens de la gastronomie tout le
monde arrive un peu à bout de chou fleur
rendu au printemps puis bon allez tu es
maintenant 2022 après ces deux années de
pandémie quelle était l'ambiance comment
étaient les gens puis comment vous en
sortez l'ambiance diarrhée l'était
et les présente c'était vraiment des
gens qui étaient en santé l'ars et la
résilience l'énergie et le goût des gens
de vouloir faire plaisir
à leurs clients à leurs consommateurs et
pour nous ça a été une grande fierté
parce que c'est les gens de l'industrie
qui décernait les prix et pour nous ça a
été une confirmation que notre mission à
sa place dans le paysage culinaire du
québec qui émane du canada et ce sont
des gens qu'on admire énormément aussi
donc et ce qui est incroyable avec vous
c'est que je regardais vous avez vous
aviez 68 points de vote au québec
l'automne dernier vous est rendu à quoi
300 points de vente au canada
représentant puis aux états unis on
n'est pas encore aux états unis mais
c'est dans les plans d'expansion la
pandémie nous sommes vraiment propulsé
cinq ans dans notre plan d'expansion un
an et demi donc c'est vraiment pour nous
ça a été une occasion de faire les
mouvements qu'on n'osait peut-être pas
faire aussi rapidement avant la pandémie
donc mouvement par exemple vers le
prêt-à-manger le prêt-à-manger et aussi
donner plus de temps à l'expansion au
développement de deux points deux points
de vente de nos épices et on travaille
beaucoup aussi sur le développement de
nouveaux produits les produits de
consommation courante afin de rentrer
dans le garde manger dans le quotidien
les familles madame tardy baptiste fait
combien d'un exode ici au canada depuis
presque vingt ans presque 20 heures et
là donc il ya d'autres réfugiés comme ça
qui arrive à chaque année pierre roth et
beaucoup de réfugiés ukrainien quels
conseils vous donner il faut jamais
lâcher prise il faut avoir il faut venir
dans un nouveau payé à vous voir une
ambition de tourner la page c'est beau
d'avoir des belles souvenirs on a tous
des baisses souvenir qu'elle que soit
migrants ont figé mais il faut tourner
la page d'une manière que voici mon pays
comment je peux vivre et avoir ma place
dans ce nouveau les pays en sa chambre
le canada c'est un pays qui est très à
coller accueillant pour tout les
réfugiés il ouvre grand ses mains pour
accueillir c'est les immigrants et les
réfugiés l'autre quoi vous êtes sans
doute heures un exemple absolument
exceptionnelle à suivre à regarder et
pour d'autres et pour d'autres gens qui
arrivent ici et qui veulent se lancer en
affaires ou vivre et s'intégrer à la
société en france et par dessus le
marché merci beaucoup madame tarzi bachy
merci madame comme occultation merci
beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]